but when you look at silicon valley one
of the things people
um don't understand is that if you are
capable of building a product
and a team and getting customers if you
can build
any of those three two of the three or
even one of the three
you are gonna get meetings if you can
build a great product
build a great team or get customers any
combination of those
you will go from being a bootstrapped
company to a company that's a fundable
company
don't waste your time on the debt don't
waste your time on the pitch
don't waste your time on networking
until
you have a great mvp minimum viable
product a prototype
don't waste your time on trying to get
meetings and coffee meetings with people
until you've got
a member or two of your team and don't
try to get the meeting with all the
partners until you have a couple of
customers these meetings
will take up all your time trying to get
them to burn all your time
and you could have put that into
bootstrapping and actually building the
mvp of your product
now if your product is not
bootstrappable
like you want to build a car company
well you might need to start with a
business
before building a car company because
your
if you have no credibility you have no
track record you don't get
to be trusted with the 50 million
dollars it might take to get a car out
the door
or the 150 million it takes to do drug
discovery
and or get a medical device out there
you might need to work on a software
business before that
or you might need to work for somebody
else's car company or somebody else's
biotech company
so again about this being fair if you're
a nobody with no track record
put yourself in the capital allocator
shoes would you give them 10 million or
100 million dollars i hope not
i hope you wouldn't do that that would
not be wise you need to have people who
have experience who've done it before
if you want to do those big big projects
and if you think about it
and tesla elon funded with his own money
that he made
building a software company zip2 so you
should know the history of these things
it's really hard to do the hardware
projects
direct to consumer or consumer packaged
goods
when you look at those they tend to not
have high margins
uh unless they're direct consumers and
they are uh easy to 2x or 10x those
businesses but can you 100x them
they're a little bit harder so you don't
see too many
businesses and direct to consumer or
consumer packaged goods getting
funding from venture capitals we had a
little bit of a direct consumer boom
for sure with casper eight sleep and
other companies
but it's really hard the product needs
to be super differentiated
has to be a very unique product like the
peloton maybe
or the eight sleep bed any of those kind
of direct to consumer hardware
businesses physical products
there are really hard to make work uh
tonal
it's just really expensive and you have
to install it that's why they have to
charge subscription fees so some
businesses are just
not easy to do and now there's
crowdfunding
just a little exception here that's
worth noting some people will
if they're building a hardware product
be able to put it on kickstarter be able
to put it on indiegogo and get the
flywheel going
with people ordering in advance because
it's such a visionary company
the only thing i'll say is many of those
projects fail because they under charge
they think they should charge the people
who are the early adopters
less when in fact they should charge
them more they should charge them extra
for letting them be part of the
excitement of building a new product not
charge them less
and then under price themselves and get
into debt and not be able to deliver the
product so
bootstrapping means you have to have
some skills if you don't have skills
well you know how to get them just go to
youtube take a ux class
take a no code class learn how to use
the no code
platforms out there web flow bubble
there's a ton of them out there you can
start building your own
mvps in no code now this doesn't work
for every company you think about a drug
discovery company somebody's trying to
find the cure for cancer or a medical
device
where they're doing some deep tech or
building rocket ships some things are
massively capital intensive now
bootstrapping versus fundraising and at
what point
bootstrapping companies can then
become funded now it's important if you
understand that venture capital is not
a right everybody doesn't get to raise
venture capital venture capital funds a
very small percentage of businesses
in the world and venture capital is in
patient capital
venture capital is looking for
unrealistic
growth some might even argue unnatural
growth
growth in the 20 a month range
if you're growing 20 a month that means
your business is doubling every three or
four months
where do you find businesses that grow
this fast
well you only find them in the early
stages and you only find them
in truly breakout companies so why does
venture capital even exist
well it exists because every 20
30 40 companies in silicon valley some
company actually achieves
this unrealistic goal and they pay
for all the other mistakes and i'm using
air quotes in here or failed experiments
in a portfolio
so that's the dynamic of how venture
capitalists look at it
venture capital is not the only source
of fundraising in the world
so take a pause and understand number
one you
do not get to have a right to venture
capital you have no right
to get venture capital it is a
competition and the people who judge
this competition are capital allocators
known as venture capitalists
who have to find those big winners in
order to keep their jobs
that's the crazy insane
silicon valley methodology i have no
idea
why this exists or exactly how we got
here i'll be totally honest
but it exists in the world it is a very
strange part of capitalism
that this crazy venture capital even
exists in the world as a category
we used to have bank loans maybe people
raised friends and family
but you know somebody had a rich uncle
or an aunt or he got an inheritance and
that's how businesses were built or
people
inherited businesses or inherited wealth
and now you have this weird
practice of venture capital now many
founders ask me to invest in their
company
when they have an idea we don't do that
why don't we do that we don't have to
there's so many people out there who've
bootstrapped their company
and come to us with ten thousand dollars
a month in revenue or a thousand dollars
a month in revenue or fifty thousand a
month in revenue
and they have a couple of customers and
they have a product that we can use
and look at the uh how well it was built
and we can look at
the customers we can look at the growth
we can look at the churn rate
how customers leave the product how they
acquire customers
so you as a founder are in a competition
so let that sink in this is not
socialism it's not communism everybody
doesn't get a loaf of bread or
you know a certain percentage of venture
capital it is a dogged competition it is
a crazy
competition it's an unfair competition
just accept that
as the table stakes and then you will be
free to understand
how you can qualify and how you can
actually win
that competition once you have that
realization that it is unfair
that it is a dogged crazy uh fight
to get that venture capital money then
you will be free
to start thinking about what are the
precursors to getting venture capital
and maybe even do you
want it because venture capital is jet
fuel
you put jet fuel on a skateboard or a
bicycle
or a car it's just going to explode into
a fiery mess and everybody dies
jet fuel is for rocket ships and you
have to ask yourself is this business
in fact a rocket ship or is it a slow
growth or a normal growth business
remember venture capital impatient
capital
realistic growth is not what they're
looking for venture capital is looking
for unrealistic
and perhaps even unhealthy growth growth
that is going so crazy and so fast
that maybe you know the tires come
flying off or things are messy
mistakes are made but growth at all
costs
is really what venture capital is about
now people will argue that there's
conscientious capital or people are
looking for you to grow slow and steady
wins the race
people might say that but i think it's
platitudes i think in reality
venture capitalists want absurdly high
growth companies in the
double digit percentage month over month
and most businesses probably grow double
digits year over year so this is a whole
different
pace this is like sprinting versus
jogging
right or walking it's totally different
how much time and money do you spend
integrating a bunch of different
software products together at your
company
let me guess way too much time well odoo
is here to help
odoo is a suite of business apps that
runs your entire company
on one platform they'll streamline your
workflow by bringing
all of that information together plus
odoo's integrations eliminate
repetitive tasks and data entry if you
only need two or three apps to optimize
your workflow that's all you pay for
odoo won't stick you with the bill for
apps you don't use
odoo has an app for every business need
they offer 30 main apps
that are updated regularly in over 16
000 apps
from their active open source community
you can keep your books tight with their
financial software
and their sales and crm apps will help
provide a clear and organized view of
your business
so here is your call to action your
first app is free forever
and right now odoo is offering a one
thousand dollar credit
on your first implementation pack that's
not a joke that's a thousand dollars
just go to odoo.com twist
to check it out that's odo.com
twist